bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique la mission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation
lutter contre les vols d'identité et
bien c'est le travail de marie azevedo
et de son entreprise heidi vérif cartes
d'identité passeports titre de séjour la
technologie mise au point par la société
permettent de trier le vrai du faux
maria névés d'eau au m ont invité
bonjour marié et vélo vous êtes sur ce
secteur-là depuis des années et votre
technologie jusqu'à présent était assez
simple suffisait de scanner la le
document pour vérifier s'il était vrai
ou faux effectivement c'est 24 ans d
expertise des supports d'identité des
supports administratifs et en scannant
un document aujourd'hui on va pouvoir
vérifier la qualité d'un document à
travers
soi un documents contrefaits ou
falsifiés et un usage suspects du
document usurpée c'est un service qui a
beaucoup dans
concurrentiel où vous êtes la seule à
faire ça après tout l art ya 24 ans
j'étais coureur aujourd'hui j'ai inspiré
bien évidemment un grand nombre
d'initiatives mais je reste malgré tout
avec une expertise inédite avec moi un
service un savoir-faire inédit inégalée
puisque je pars de la pédagogie et
j'embarque la pédagogie sur des systèmes
techniques enfin sur des systèmes
techniques qu'ils utilisent la
technologie de pointe on travaille
surtout en mode agile et en ayant
appliqué cette forme de dévolution et
bien évidemment je m'adapte à nous les a
tous les usages qui a besoin de vérifier
l'identité d'une personne en gros qui
sont vos clients alors qui a besoin de
vérifier un document d'identité c'est
bien évidemment les banques
les organismes financiers qui reste le
maillon faible de notre système de droit
mis aujourd'hui
au delà des banques c'est aussi les
assurances et aussi toute la partie
immobilier la location immobilière la
location automobile allocation de deux
de services mais également lorsqu'on
embauche une personne on a aussi besoin
de vérifier un support d'identité
le cool très bas je crois de votre
technologie alors le coup par rapport à
nos clients pour le client mon objectif
c'était de rendre un service
accessible à tous donc avec un coût de
quelques centimes suffit pour vérifier
un document donc à chaque fois que je
scam un document ça coûte quelques
centimes celui moi je vous paie à vous
votre entreprise alors évidemment c'est
sous forme alors ça peut être sous forme
d'un d'un usage unique puis le maître
vous payez ce que vous consommez sous
forme d'un abonnement également comme et
donc donc en illimité donc aujourd'hui
on est en train de aussi de s'adapter à
tous les secteurs d'activité en fonction
des besoins et de la quantité
d'analystes de documents dont tu as
besoin l'entreprise alors concrètement
comment ça fonctionne gg quoi j'ai mon
portable je reçois cliente qu'il veut un
produit de crédit je vérifie son
identité grâce à mon portable tout
simplement à au téléphone portable 1
aujourd'hui fait office également de
scanner puisqu'on fait voilà je soutiens
le dr ozcan et le document vous vendent
au gras fier document vous digitalisées
votre document y parle par le fait de
cet acte de gif de digitalisation et
bien vous allez pouvoir des services
donc on a développé on allait pouvoir
vérifier la qualité du support la
qualité du support passe par identifier
des zones qui ont été contrefaites ou
falsifiés tout simplement mai
et là je vous donne en quelques secondes
une réponse sur le fait que votre
document soit suspect comporte une
anomalie ou pas donc clairement si on
prend par exemple je sais pas moi une
carte d'identité française
quels sont les deux trois éléments que
votre technologie va chercher pour
vérifier la qualité de ce document à on
va déjà alors les zones sont nombreuses
un lot le type de document ou
aujourd'hui on n'est pas que sur des
documents français en indre et documents
internationaux et principalement
européens parce que la fraude à
l'identité l'usurpation d'identité n'est
pas exact onale elle est vraiment
internationale et aujourd'hui on sait
lire et aussi bien des documents
français que européen mais selon la
typologie des documents et bien ça va
être bien évidemment un nom qui va et et
quelques heures a été modifié une date
de naissance mais la photo surtout sur
la photo parce que dans la plupart des
cas on va utiliser devrait donner
aujourd'hui en tout cas notre constat
c'est que on va utiliser devrait donner
d'un vrai citoyen européen mais par
contre on va intégrer une photo qui sera
là la photo du porteur mais non pas du
tout d'une titulaire des données donc en
gros je le vole une carte d'identité
d'un citoyen européen je veux simplement
remplacer la photo alors volé presque
pas parce qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez
même pas besoin de voler le support à
l'entité vous avez scanner un document
vous l'avais envoyé par mail à une
tierce personne eh bien on peut
intercepter c'est le risque cyber qui
aujourd'hui est une menace un enjeu de
société on pince intercepter des données
personnelles on peut intercepter
notamment un document
un document d'identité et parce qu'on
l'aura intercepter les données sont tout
à fait correct sauf la photo qu'on aura
intégré une nouvelle photo a ordonné
d'un vrai tulsa vous arrivez avec fait
pas la bonne photo alors ça on arrive
bien évidemment c'est aussi une
expérience de 24 ans une expérience
issue d'une analyse ode au delà de
documents de support lui-même et c'est
aussi des comportements
mais sans ses fers documents d'identité
passeports titre de séjour etc dans
toute l'europe aussi les états unis
enfin il n'y a pas de carte d'identité
aux états unis il ya des dix ans pour
conduire les voitures c'est ça voilà est
allé driving licence sont les permis de
conduire alors évidemment tous les
supports normes et aujourd'hui on est
capable de les livres bien évidemment et
les supports semi normes et enfin en
tout cas il ya des documents comme les
bulletins de paye une somme énorme et on
s'est quand même les lire et on les a on
a automatisé également la lecture des
bulletins chiffre d'affaires de notre
entreprise alors pour ce qui est des dix
vérif c'est un démarrage aujourd'hui
alors c'est un démarrage même s'il
expertise et vient d'une société que
j'écris le réseau compte que vous aurez
plus de 84 ans voilà donc aujourd'hui a
dit vérifient capitalise toutes les
expertises kaka développer réseau comme
pour
bourbon le grison comme c'est quoi lol
le chiffre d'affaires alors le chiffre
d'affaires de faire de réseaux comme on
est autour de 3 millions d'euros pour
combien de salariés
alors aujourd'hui que kovy demain obligé
à organiser à réorganiser évidemment ma
masse salariale
on y au moins
10 salariés d'accord donc plutôt
profitable commun oui comme société donc
là vous vous lancer un nouveau produit
enfin nouvelles façons de
d'enquêté sur la fraude au document en
gros vous lancer une plateforme où vous
dites à ceux qui ont perdu ou qu'on volé
leur carte d'identité 2 déclarait
absolument l'idée de la plate forme a
dit vérif et de capitaliser donc toutes
les expertises qui ont été faites depuis
24 ans c'est à dire qu'un citoyen va
pouvoir venir enregistrer enfin en tout
cas taper son numéro de documents non le
type de document et l'origine du pays
parce qu'évidemment il n'y a pas que des
documents français et il ya une réponse
instantanée qui précise si ce document a
été identifié comme étant contrefaits ou
falsifiés non on anomalies chez nous ou
alors si toutefois il est victime
d'usurpation d'identité si toutefois il
a perdu son document il craint d'être
victime d'usurpation d'identité il peut
s'enrichir enregistrer gratuitement
également dans la plate forme de vase
ont enregistré son numéro et si son
numéro apparaît au sein d'eads et des
banques parce que évidemment c'est une
plateforme intelligente est une
plateforme qui va s'enrichir en fonction
de l'usagé si son document vient à
paraître il ils recevraient une alerte
disons qu'on lui a valu de dix ans une
tierce personne ne tentera d'utiliser
son identité ou est là et c'est comme ça
que je caractérise des comportements
frauduleux mars à fait gratuit c'est
gratuit je m'inscrive ce gratuit c'est
quoi le modèle business de votre
plateforme alors au delà de cette partie
gratuite il ya évidemment des services
combien qu'on est en train de mettre en
place notamment la la la le lob des
services liés à la mise en relation avec
des professionnels des avocats
spécialisés des psychologues spécialisés
des enquêteurs également donc l'idée
c'est aussi d'apporter une assistance à
l'ensemble des victimes d'usurpation
d'identité parce que souvent ils sont
démunis ils ne savent pas vers qui ils
doivent sur ce
et donc l'objectif c'est vraiment de les
accompagner alors au delà de les
accompagner on va produire également un
rapport qui précise le lieu géographique
l'heure et le lieu géographique d'où son
document a été utilisé par un usurpateur
en est donc évidemment ça rentre en
relation avec les banques le crédit
qu'ils seront alertés sur l'identité
votre société quand même à part est-ce
que vous avez des propositions de rachat
par des grosses boîtes qui s'intéresse à
votre technologie alors
depuis 24 ans je suis seule au capital
j'ai tout auto investi j'ai tout un
développer et investit tout seul
effectivement j'ai certaines tentatives
de
beaucoup d'intérêt je n'ai pas encore
aujourd'hui
acter le fait que je puisse m'associer
mais j'ouvre le débat ma des
propositions sérieuses ce serait avec un
grand intérêt puisque
capitaliser un savoir-faire de 24 ans ça
peut effectivement faire gagner du temps
à d'autres entreprises qui souhaitent se
positionner sur le sur le sujet sur le
marché et pour grandir dernière question
au niveau international man ah j'en rêve
je rêve parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui a
été fait en france c'est inédit et
évidemment il ya un besoin également de
de cloner en ce service à
l'international merci beaucoup maria
névés d'eau pour vos réponses
l'entretien de l'intelligence économique
est bien c'est terminé mais évidemment
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
france 24 points comme sur nos réseaux
sociaux évidemment sur nos podcasts au
revoir
[Musique]